Elysium is a fictional side-like  community in space created for society's  Elites who Escape Earth which has become  a third world it actually spins a full  rotation every six minutes to imitate  Earth's gravity and with a 377 square  kilometer of habitable surface it can  host up to 890 000 people in a Suburban  flat environment but if it was designed  as an urban environment it could host up  to 10 million people it's got a thin  layer of plasma that's strong enough to  prevent air from escaping but it's weak  enough to allow ships to pass through  even though the technology is not as  realistic the level of thought in the  construction is really amazing if you  look closely you will see that  everything is built in modules a lot of  the panels are in sizes that are  realistic enough to transport them from  Earth to space meaning the modules were  probably prefabricated on Earth and  brought to site to be assembled